good morning believe nation today's
message is embrace your uniqueness over
to you Nina Dobrev honestly I think
everyone is different and unique and
that's a good thing it's not mad it's
kind of the best thing in the world you
don't want to be like everyone else
growing up in high school and just doing
your hide with your whole life really
either you have been taught to feel like
or you want to be like everyone else
because conceptually you'll you'll be
included and you'll be like the crowd
but when you think about it when you
look at people like Lady gaga
who is so crazy it's so different and so
unique and her whole message is about
you know being yourself and being okay
with it and she the reason she is so
successful and so is because she's
talented because she's different if she
was just like Britney Spears or if she
was just like Minami nina dobrev then
there would be two of us so there'd be
nothing special about that so I think
what's what's special is the fact that
you're different and is the fact that
you're unique and that you can bring
something to the table so if anything
embrace that that that uniqueness and
that that thing that you have that no
one else does and expand upon it make it
better and tell everyone about it and be
confident in that because if you're
confident and happy and smiling you will
attract confidence happiness and
laughter people keep trying to copy the
successes of other people because they
think it's what's going to make them win
and you can to some extent you can model
success but if all you're doing is
copying somebody steps after steps at
their steps the best you're going to be
is a second or third rate version of
them instead of the best version of you
and this is what's really really
important as you begin on your path it's
okay to copy other people you're looking
for guidance you're looking for
inspiration you have no idea how
anything is done and so instead of
trying to figure out every single idea
yourself model success learn from people
who come before you it's a fantastic
strategy
but if you want to win the big game if
you want to really be unique and really
different and really stand out and
really have massive success it's going
to come from you taking these bits of
pieces from other people if you're going
to work to them and then tweaking them
to apply to your situation there's a
great example like the reference on the
channel talking about 50 cent looking at
new people coming up through the
industry and people sending him demo
tapes and people that sound like Lil
Wayne and so you sound just like Lil
Wayne I can't tell the difference
between you a little Wayne it's amazing
your talent to sound like Lil Wayne is
fantastic but we already have a little
Wayne we don't need a little Wayne
copycat so the best you're going to do
here is just be a little Wayne cover
band is that what you want to do where
you have uniqueness you have talent
inside you you can find a way to tweak
some of the things that works a little
Wayne and apply to your situation to be
an amazing artist I found this when I
was working on my youtube channel and I
was working with my agent I had my agent
Steve and I had a media coach Janie who
worked at the agency and they were
giving me feedback on how to make better
videos and I would meet with Janie once
a week for a year and a half and I met
with Steve maybe once a month looking at
different videos and you would always
give me feedback and totally different
style feedback Steve was always rhesus
takes very aggressive Weiser why is it
so important what are some of the bail
to kill themselves before watching this
video and you had to make that
transition to help them stay alive right
like just make it more important and
Janie is leaning on authenticity
understand and be genuine and a much
softer side and so every time I met with
both of them they would give me
different feedback and they see it
through their lens and I would always
take their advice and I would struggle
with it and I would do exactly what they
said Steve give me homework I would do
exactly what he asked Janie gave me
homework I could do exactly what she had
and it always felt uncomfortable which
was good
searching the comfort zone but it was
never quite right for me and what I had
to do is take that awesome piece of
advice from Janie and add just a little
bit to it make it shift so that it
worked for me it felt more authentic
felt more comfortable felt more Evon and
that's what you need to do look at all
the strategies of people that have gone
out what they've done before you it's
amazing and then see how can I make that
thing that work for Steve Jobs work for
me what tweak can I make
to make it authentic and uniquely me so
that I will have success in this market
because if you don't do that again
you're just going to be a copy of
somebody else and you're never going to
stand out and have massive success you
have amazingness inside you and you need
to let that out trust that it's there
embrace it and go all-in on it so the
question today is I'm curious what have
you learned from somebody else that
you've modeled and then tweak what was
the tweak I'm curious what did you learn
and then how did you tweak it to make it
fit and work for you leave in the
comments below super curious to find out
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Juliette young Juliette thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really really really
means a lot to me and I appreciate the
support I hope you enjoyed the read
thank you guys again for watching I hope
you have an amazing day I believe in you
and hope you continue to believe in
yourself and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot
events better
[Music]
saying that we have enough artists is
like saying we have enough scientists we
have enough designers we have enough
politicians we have enough politicians
but you know nobody gets to be you
except you nobody has your point of view
except you
nobody gets to bring to the world the
things that you get to bring to the
world uniquely get to bring to the world
except you so saying there are enough
writers out enough directors out there
enough people with points of view well
yeah there are but none of them are you
and not only none of those people is
going to make the art that you will make
none of them will change people and
change the world in the way that you
could change it so if you believe
somebody who says no no we got enough of
those then all it means is you're giving
up your chance to change the world in
the way that only you could change it
everybody is the same and I run into
these people I feel like we like I
nobody is a real real individual like
it's rare that you stumble across
someone who's a real individual when you
do it's like amazing it I love seeing
people who are just truly themselves but
everybody is like whenever they see on
TV whatever they see around and they
just want to be then it's like you don't
world is huge you don't have to be that
you do not have to be with what your
neighbor is did you have to do what your
neighbor is doing you can do whatever
the you want so people are just like
yeah rappers flight they have to be a
certain way actors like they have to be
a certain way people in certain
neighborhoods like that if you're
selling Lakers who then around and I
know deep down like um like children
children are themselves they react off
of instinct until they start to
understand how the world is and human I
mean an adults when once they turn into
an adult they're they start to see like
oh dang okay I can't do that I can't
like that number I can't I can't be that
way because that's that's not acceptable
because I might keep I might look down
upon they might laugh at me or think I'm
weird and it's like know that this is
what makes you you this is what makes
you you like I I just try and it's hard
to do don't get me wrong like I'm I'm
still learning about myself I'm trying
to just um open myself up to new ways of
thinking all the time and just truly
being my
sometimes I get caught in something next
to so many different levels to a matrix
you know saying sometimes you like them
I thought I was out and I was still in
right I guess you just but um that's
rail yeah it's just everybody just feels
like they have to be just like everybody
else and when I when I see rappers I'm
like : Dooley get your sit down same
dance doing the same turn and it's like
do you got you got a billion tattoos on
your face and body where did you get
that from because you I know you didn't
come out of your mom's vagina going I
want to be tatted you saw somebody do
that and you said I want to do that too
because that's going to make me look
like this type of thing and I want to be
just like that I'm and everybody's doing
it I know that works so I'm going to do
it and now it makes you look like one of
them and now you're now you're not
original and then your rap career
doesn't go for you like well what
happened then it's just in it but it's
not just rapping it's just all areas of
life what samsara means hard work saying
power means every day you get up and you
try to how to stay away stay ahead of
the pack I've sort of marched to the
beat of your own drummer
this notion that music becomes
modernized in other words there are lots
of successful rappers that have short
careers because if you can replace one
rapper for another you're done but more
unique you are and what you do to better
your chances of continuing on so when
you take a look at that sometimes it's
musical take a look at a band like ac/dc
you hear it you immediately know what it
is that's what they serve up you want
balance go to another band they serve up
straighter that's what you do kiss
serves up spectacle we will not sit
around on stage on a Persian carpet
light the candles and sing about oh the
flaxen-haired lass and leaving this
countryside kill me now we don't do that
you know you want nice quiet stay at
home with Grandma pour another glass of
water and put our false teeth in it let
the spinach rise to the top I think what
we do we blow stuff up with a drummer
and a backbeat and don't sing about the
secret of life because there is none
here's the secret of life you're alive
and then you're not that's it that's the
secret be glad you're alive while you're
alive you're a lot too
shake the world up a little bit and
that's what you do